March is almost upon us and just like
every month a truckload of new offerings
will be dropping on Netflix there's
something for everyone coming to the
streaming site in March 2020 but if you
happen to be a big fan of prestige
dramas romantic comedies or both you're
really in luck
while the action-packed offerings
arriving on Netflix in March 2020 are
just a little bit thin
there's still a few flicks sure to get
your eternal and pumping for some
pulse-pounding action check out haywire
a 2011 actioner directed by Steven
Soderbergh known for entertaining films
such as Magic Mike and Logan lucky
haywire features an absolutely sterling
cast led by Gina Carano who you may
recognize from her ass-kicking turns at
Deadpool and the Disney Plus series the
mandalorian Carano stars as Mallory Kane
a dangerous government operative who
finds herself targeted by her own shady
employers the supporting cast includes
Michael Fassbender Ewan McGregor
Channing Tatum Michael Douglas Antonio
Banderas and the late great Bill Paxton
also on tap in March as cop-outs a buddy
cop comedy which stars he intriguingly
we are duo of Bruce Willis and Tracy
Morgan hook a 1991 Steven Spielberg
directed fantasy which focuses on an
adult Peter Pan played by Robin Williams
and his titular nemesis played by Dustin
Hoffman and the 2004 theatrical
adaptation of Lemony Snicket's A Series
of Unfortunate Events which stars Jim
Carrey as the villainous Count Olaf all
of these hit the streaming service on
March 1st you want dramas Netflix has
got dramas March 1st alone brings a
wealth of hard-hitting fare including a
pair of excellent mob flicks in Donnie
Brasco so ignore Pacino and Johnny Depp
and Martin Scorsese's masterpiece
Goodfellas also dropping a much first
itse Oscar nominated Stephen King
adaptation the Shawshank Redemption and
the Paul Thomas Anderson directed there
will be blood which earned a star Daniel
day-lewis an Academy Award for Best
Actor I drink your milkshake
I drink it up on March 16th you can
check out silver linings playbook which
nab started a for Lawrence an Academy
Award for Best Actress March 16th also
brings a cold war drama Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy to the streaming giant which
sports a ridiculous cast including Gary
Oldman Tom Hardy Colin Firth Benedict
Cumberbatch and John Hurt finally March
27th brings a vastly underrated 2012
neo-noir killing them softly which
centers on a trio of small-time hoods on
the run from a pair of mob hit men
portrayed by Brad Pitt's and the latest
James Gandolfini rom-com fans have a lot
to look forward to in march 2020
premiering on Netflix on the first of
the month alone are always a bridesmaid
souring job easier Leslie ghosts of
Girlfriends Past with Matthew
McConaughey and he's just not that into
you which features an all-star cast
including Jennifer Aniston Ben Affleck
Scarlett Johansson Bradley Cooper
Jennifer Connelly and Justin long also
premiering a March 1st our life as we
know it
starring Katherine Heigl and Josh
Duhamel and sleepover which features
Alexa Vega
Steve Carell Evan pizzas and pre
superstardom brie Larson and while it
arrived a little late for the actual
holiday you could also catch the Garry
Marshall directed Valentine's Day on
March 1st
starring Ashton Kutcher Taylor Swift
Julia Roberts Bradley Cooper and
Jennifer Garner good evening
Plus March 1st brings a 1982 Dustin
Hoffman classic Tootsie which co-stars
Bill Murray and Tina Davis and was
directed by the great Sydney [ __ ]
fans of Bugs Bunny and his pals are also
in for a treat in March 2020 as a pair
of Awesome selections warhead Netflix on
March 1st you'll be able to catch the
1996 live-action and animation mashup
Space Jam as well as the underrated
hilarious 2003 brendan fraiser starring
looney tunes back in action Netflix will
field an absolutely poetry new crop of
horror and thriller releases in March
2020 if you dig the Resident Evil series
you'll find 2004 so pocalypse and 2007 s
extinction available for streaming on
the first of the month and they account
for two of the three new offerings for
the month in total the third however
it's a very definition of an underrated
gem
Sam Raimi's 2000 psychological horror
flick at the gift the movie stars Kate's
blonde
sheds a zani a small-town psychic and
widow who foresaw our own husband's
death she begins to have similarly
disturbing visions involving her best
friend Valerie whose abusive husband
Donnie is a looming presence in her
visions Keanu Reeves plays Donnie
delivering her performance completely
unlike anything you have ever seen out
of him before while Oscar winner Hillary
Swank plays Valerie the gift was Raimi's
last film before tackling the seminal
superhero flicks spider-man and is fun
to see JK Simmons and rosemary Harris he
would go on to portray J jonah Jameson
and Aunt May respectively in minor roles
here if you're a fan of tight tents
rulers you owe it to yourself to check
this flick out as is usually the case
Netflix will be offering up a few
intriguing standup sets during march
2020
March 3rd check out cross a life crisis
the first solo special from Taylor
Tomlinson my friends like you need the
guy with a car and a job and I'm like
yeah then I got to deal with his wife
like it's a whole thing she may be only
25 but she's seemingly been plying her
trade forever and has been a regular on
the late-night talk show circuit since
making her TV debut on Last Comic
Standing in 2015 March 10th will see the
release of end times fun the new special
for Marc Maron you may recognize him as
the host of the WTF with Marc Maron
podcast or perhaps ferry's appearances
in feature films like sorts of trust and
joker he also starred in his eponymous
sitcom Maron from 2013 to 2016 on the
IFC network and he currently stars as
Sam Silvia on the hit Netflix series
glow finally on March 17th you can watch
hey big boy the latest stand-up set from
the Troyer's party dude Bert Kreischer
in case you're not familiar with his
comedic aesthetic just know that in 1997
Chrysler was featured in a Rolling Stone
article in which he was designated the
top part here the number one party
school in the country Florida State
University crisis exploits were the
basis for the classic comedy feature Van
Wilder the movie which helped to make
Ryan Reynolds a household name last but
not least Netflix will be offering a
small but scintillating selection of new
television seasons in March 2020 the
long-awaited third season of the hit
animated series Castlevania war premiere
and March 5th
followed by a slightly more irrelevant
animated offering season 2 of the
hilarious paradise PD on March 6th also
dropping that day is season 2 of ugly
the fascinating documentary / cooking
show / travelogue posted by the
generally charismatic chef David Chang
Mike 17th will bring us season 2 of The
CW sports drama all-american and season
3 of that Network superhero series Black
Lightning which has a long last been
established of a connection to the shows
of the era verts via the recent massive
crossover event crisis on Infinite
Earths finally March 27th will see the
release of season 3 of Ozark the Jason
Bateman starring crime drama which has
kept fans waiting for about a year and a
half for new episodes
Peyman portrays marty bird a crooked
financial planner who relocates his
family from Chicago to Missouri after a
money laundering scheme blows up in his
face
unfortunately for him he's indebted to a
Mexican drug cartel and things I can get
any less tense after the families move
if you haven't yet caught ozark now
would be a good time to catch up on the
first two seasons which are pretty great
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]